am donnerstag findet die
niederösterreichischen weiterer ein
zentrales partner seminar statt dabei
bedankt sich das österreichische
bundesheer bei seinen vielen partnern
für die erfolgreiche zusammenarbeit in
den vergangenen jahren
und diese partnerschaften haben auch
einen großen anteil an der erfolgreichen
bewältigung der herausfordernden
einsätze denen sich das bundesheer in
den vergangenen monaten zu stellen hat
und so ist es für partnerschaften wenn
man vertrauensvolle partnerinnen und
partner auch an der seite hat und der
heutige tadelte heutige
festveranstaltung sollen
mit urkunden werden die partner für die
gute zusammenarbeit ausgezeichnet und
wertgeschätzt